how bad is this I mean it does take some
experience with the chemistry to really
know that silkaggiano is an expert in
this he's a Hazardous Waste Authority he
says the town of East Palestine has
effectively been nuked he joins us
tonight to explain what that means so I
appreciate your coming on
um how do you having
spent your life assessing things like
chemical spills how do you assess the
condition of East Palestine tonight
it's very Troublesome these poor
individuals for through no fault of
their own became victims of you know
systemic failures within the the
transportation rail the rail
transportation system and it manifested
itself in this mushroom cloud that they
they had to experience in their Town one
of the reasons why I made the comment
about you know we nuked the town with
chemicals is because there was somebody
from Darlington Pennsylvania who was
videoing uh the cloud that had went over
his property and you could see Fallout
coming out of the cloud going onto his
property and I'm looking at it and
saying you know it reminds you of one of
those apocalyptic shows where the
nuclear fallout's coming out and I
thought about it I says well yeah we
basically did nuke a whole town just to
get a railroad going you know back in
service and
earlier on I got involved in this
because
news media were not being told the truth
days into this no you know contrary
concept was available they didn't know
what they had and you know that flies in
the face of logic if you're going to
mitigate a problem if you're going to
have your fire department and other you
know responding teams take care of it
you should know what the heck you've got
and it got to the point where they were
showing me pictures of train cars the
local media and I was identifying what
was in based on unid numbers or train
car numbers
and when they told me their plan you
know at that point you had a few cars
burning they had unmonitored hand lines
there keeping the tankers cool and then
I find out that they're pulling the
unmonitored hand lines keeping the
tankers cool and so that's just going to
cause the uh the tanker cars to heat up
which they did and then they announced
that one was during a very near
catastrophic failure and I said well if
they don't put water back on it it's
going to continue to heat up and it's
going to what's called a bloody and it's
going to damage other containers and
then I was told no they're going to
detonate all these cars so that it
doesn't happen I could tell you Mr
Carlson I've been looking at rail
incidents over and over because in
Youngstown Ohio there's three Rail lines
that run through our town so as a chief
and as a instructor I trained my guys to
anticipate stuff and I would go case
study After Case Study after case study
coming up with different scenarios just
to keep it going and I've never once in
39 years ever heard of them blowing up
train cars dumping all the chemicals
into a trench and lighting them on fire
I was you know I was dumbfounded and you
know when you lit this stuff on fire you
were creating fog jeans you're creating
hydrogen chlorides you created this
plume and up in this plume was all the
incomplete combustion products of
everything that was there
um stuff if you looked at the guy's
video stuff is precipitating down into
people's property there's a lot of
questions uh you know in the answers
came slow
and you know first you get well now
we've found vinyl chlorides in the water
well yeah
no joke you're going to find that uh you
know and you're each it seemed like
everything was drips and dribbles
instead of you know one of the things I
learned is you tell the truth you tell
it all you tell it first and you tell
them how you're going to solve the
problem and none of that was forthcoming
and I began to worry about you know what
the end result with this is going to be
they had evacuated one mile and I was
telling the media they better do like
one and a half two miles well
subsequently after that they went to two
miles
and then within a few minutes they were
bringing a few days they're bringing
everybody back and that was pretty much
just in time to open up the rails and
there was no testing there's got to be
some plan going forward in this cleanup
and Recovery to test
yeah I mean if you find asbestos in your
building you contain and remove it you
don't blow it into the next County it
just seems self-evidently insane so I
appreciate your coming on tonight that
was really really interesting and sad
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight